absolutely right that that the
fetishization of government or the
replacement of what we used to have as
the foundation of our civilization in
our society with the state it does seem
that they've become quite tribal what do
you make of this Berkeley was the
beginning of the Free Speech Movement
FSM in the 1960s now they're the
opposite of the Free Speech Movement is
there some bizarre change that's
happened or even in that free speech
movement was it similarly a bit of a
misnomer and really just a way to
advance left-wing goals such as
protesting the Vietnam War well yeah I
actually had this shapiro auntie poster
that i wanted to show you this is meant
in 1964 and in 2015 so it's a bunch of
cops in riot gear in 2016 that
apparently guard fascist some is yeah
it's absolutely incredible no the new
her speech movement was yes to establish
free speech for individuals who believe
marxist ideologies in the sixty
nonetheless and when able nonetheless
they were able to espouse their views on
college campuses now we're worth
receiving that same pushback by a
liberal administration in the present
and the reason that we filed a lawsuit
against the University of California
Berkeley the young America's Foundation
and coordination with Berkeley College
Republicans is that they're they have
created policies that they apply to
restrict conservative ideology speeches
on campus this is a violation of the
process of our constitutional rights of
free speech and equal protection under
the law these are incredibly problematic
you are thinking about it in the long
term what if in the future it's the
liberals who are suppressed by a
conservative of our core and that's what
I always bring up to the Liberals
because you asked me why are you suing
the school why are you creating this
litigation that's gonna waste taxpayer
dollars and I always have to report with
well what if you're in this scenario
what if you were locked in a second
story of a ballroom with m80 fireworks
be thrown at you what if your friends
were assaulted David will and they are
we have I'm sorry go ahead
they always
they always nod their head they
reciprocate and they usually sign up for
a mailing list our we are one of the
biggest political organizations on
campus we have over 14 thousand
individuals sorry interested but only a
hundred four more meetings and that's
what the left has done they've made
conservatives incredibly take well
that's better than us Yael I think we
had about 11 members we were the most
written about 10% club on campus but
that is a really good work that you're
doing Bradley